[Musique]
le lendemain matin
le coq chante à leur île fermiers se
réveilla tu comptes
ou off est au réveil alors ça change
toute la journée c'est ça l'ordre et un
peu plus tard au petit déjeuner en
famille
le fermier déclara qu'il était très
satisfait et qu'il leur part donnait
tous les papas on n'a rien fait ça ne
fait rien je vous parle donne quand même
et dans la joie générale la vie à la
ferme recommence accord
[Musique]
et
savez vous ma chère que j'ai entendu la
fermière dit comme les enfants iront à
l'école et moi figurez-vous que l'autre
jour j'ai entendu ceci à l'on commet
toujours aussi bavarde est aussi
malveillante dans la forêt j'ai oublié
combien c'était fatigant de vous
entendre
taisez-vous main je veux une
tranquillité absolue compris which you
with you et l'autre coque et il ne fait
rien
[Musique]
le
je suis là jo je m'appelle hubert bon
hébert tu te tiens dans l'autre coin et
tu tâche de faire respecter l'ordre vue
[Musique]
oui jo compris c'est un jeudi coque vous
en mouvement de rien 1
c'est à lui que je m'adresse comment
déjà hubert pour te servir jo bon film
maintenant avez vous été sage
bon alors grand papa va vous raconter
une belle histoire une très belle
histoire
voyez-vous mais petit j'étais en grand
danger
oui alors prenons tout mon courage je
suis partie de la ferme
oui j'ai traversé la forêt j'ai traversé
la forêt disait je me suis fait des amis
avec eux j'ai combattu le renard est
évidemment le renard vaincu et me voilà
de retour
voyez-vous mes petits quand on a des
amis des vrais amis tout est possible
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]